how many of us were introduced to Robin
Hood through the Disney movie well I can
certainly say I was and it's interesting
because I think this is the only Disney
film where all the characters are anima
morphic life forms
oh there's other movies where they use
them but I think this is the first one
where every character throughout the
entire flick is half-human half-animal
there's no people I'm not sure why they
decided to make this the only one but
damn works okay having Robin Hood as a
fox is a clever idea Little John is this
gigantic bear that works out pretty well
and the others lend their way to a lot
of creative jokes also okay what's the
story well as Robin Hood goes I guess it
follows it pretty close Robin Hood Rob's
from the rich and gives to the poor in
order to defeat Prince John he's in love
with the lovely Maid Marian and tries to
win an archery contest but gets caught
in the process only to fight off the men
through many battles and many
fundraising adventures there's a lot of
the cutes eNOS that you'd expect from a
film like this but actually there are
some very entertaining action scenes
despite it being animated I'd say many
of these scenes are just as in present
as the Errol Flynn version you can get
away with a lot more so it looks more
impressive Robin is pretty much your
very basic nice hero and Maid Marian is
very much a very typical knight maiden
just a nice little romance to soak up
the kids attention they stay in their
basic roles and I guess that works out
okay have you ever noticed that Maid
Marian just disappears in the last third
until they get married couldn't at least
have a scene races could by door before
he goes off to adventure or maybe she's
helping out with the scheme or maybe
she's watching him as he's running away
I don't know she had so many scenes
before why just cut her out of the third
act plenty who the villain is Prince
John and he's a very fun comedic villain
especially when working off of his
psychic it's he's definitely a very FEM
evylyn and a lot of times that leads to
a lot of very funny moments including
some great arguments with hiss which
makes them look very much like a married
couple
I knew it I just knew this would happen
I tried to warn you but no no no you
wouldn't listen you just had to seven
years bad luck when watching it again I
actually found the Sheriff of Nottingham
was pretty funny too he's just such a
bastard in the various ways they'll find
to rip people off even a blind person
that is evil what I did a trick the
climax is one of the best in Disney
history I know that's weird seeing how
they're all cutesy animals but it's a
really suspenseful climax
the first half of it is done very much
in silence a lot of whispering a lot of
quiet music a lot of sneaking around and
then once the cover is blown it's just
fast paced action throughout the rest of
it
it's just free because everywhere the
main character turns there's always
something else trying to get him he just
cannot get a break throughout this
entire scene you got arrows flying Adam
axes henchmen fire and it just keeps
building higher and higher throughout
the castle it's a really good setup
hmm
overall Robin Hood is a very good kids
adventure film it's not great and I
don't know how many great things are
really in it but it is very entertaining
some parts drag but when it doesn't it's
a lot of fun kids will definitely love
it and I guess as some of the adults
might find themselves getting sucked in
as well
Oh